le 22 octobre dernier le corps de jeune
etc dalcourt et retrouver sur cette
piste cyclable à longueuil
la jeune fille de 23 ans a été battu à
mort après avoir été agressé
sexuellement selon des sources
policières deux jours plus tôt à moins
d'un kilomètre de là une autre femme
aurait été battue et violée chez vous
criez nous débattre avec personne pour
m'aider et me fait me créer à 18h30 le
20 octobre
il fait nuit quand carol tome en marche
de l'arrêt d'autobus jusqu'à l'institut
de théologie pour la francophonie
un homme sort de sa voiture pour
l'agresser il a réussi à me transporter
sur son épaule comme une poche de
patates et m'a jeté sur le siège depuis
s'est jeté sur moi je me retrouve la
prise avec cet inconnu qui met fosso sa
voiture qui se jette sur moi qui est
très lo comme une brique sur mon corps
est là une mafia il me retient il
m'empêche de crier et l'étouffé crime et
au flipper ralement l'homme frappe et
violent la mère monoparentale pendant
plus de 20 minutes selon elle l'a refilé
son pantalon et tout jeter le mien est
ouvert la portière images étaient hors
de la voiture d'un des chefs
carole restent accroupis sur l'asphalté
quelques minutes sous le choc d'être
encore en vie
elle n'a qu'une idée retourner chez elle
s'occuper de sa fille le lendemain matin
elle trouve le courage d'aller porter
plainte à la police
des questions j'en la victime une
croyante pratiquante
ils me posaient des questions que je
comprenais pas pourquoi il insistait que
c'était pertinent comme exemple quelle
était la taille du pénis de votre
agresseur
si jamais vous vous mettez le grappin
sur cette personne c'est quoi vous allez
me demandez peut-être de se masturber
pour vous suggérer la femme est amené à
l'hôpital où une trousse médico légal et
dûment remplies les blessures sont
documentés un choc post traumatique
diagnostic et carole et rapidement
accepté au programme d'indemnisation des
victimes d'actes criminels
mais la police de lons
guèye ne la rappelle pas pour dresser un
portrait robot de son agresseur comme on
lui avait dit qu'on le ferait après deux
mois d'attenté la victime demande l'aide
de la présidente du conseil du statut de
la femme
on a beaucoup parlé d'agression sexuelle
cet automne on a dit aux femmes qu'il
fallait qu'elle dénonce leur agresseur
la voici une femme qui le fait qu'ils
aient structuré qui a beaucoup
d'éléments et le service de police ne
l'appelle pas pour qu'elle puisse tracer
un portrait robot de son agresseur je ne
comprends pas à la police de longueuil
ont dit ne pas pouvoir commenter
officiellement une enquête en cours
mais au téléphone le porte parole de la
police tommy lacroix nous a dit il ya de
grandes zones grises dans l'histoire de
la dame
je vous parle à mots couverts madame
langlois vous comprenez il ya de grandes
lacunes dans la plainte initiale
la police semble douter de la
crédibilité de la plainte
même si 48 heures plus tard je nique
dalcourt est trouvée morte dans le même
secteur
trois mois plus tard la police de
longueuil n'a toujours pas dresser de
portraits robots dans le dossier de
madame thomas je trouve vraiment que ces
délais la pour les victimes sont
inacceptables parce que c'est une autre
forme de victimisation
deux experts en affaires policières nous
ont dit qu'il est très anormal
d'attendre si longtemps avant de faire
le portrait robot d'un agresseur
on m'a agressée comme abattu qu'on m'a
violée comme à jeter c'est pas important
ça c'est inadmissible
ils n'ont pas accorder l'importance à
cette terreur que j'ai expérimenté
madame thomas s'est résigné à dénoncer
publiquement la police de longueuil
quand l'intervention de la présidente du
conseil du statut de la femme n'a rien
donné
ici se fit langlois radio canada
montréal